okay we should be live
here morning
folks been getting late starts lately
but uh looks like we got some good
results look at
this looks like
um and we might actually have a cool
policy to check out later today on the
this is really
interesting I didn't expect
that well I mean we'll see how this uh
we'll see how this goes this could just
be it found some exploit either way
though it's in the right
direction um posted a couple
things earlier
today but I think the main thing we're
going to be doing right at the
moment is
uh where is
it merging some PRS from Discord SL
stream
whatever also still looking for
contributors for this project if
anyone's
interested
okay think we'll start with the uh
contributor PRS
so this is the one for breakout it looks
like
this is the
main main
thing you also can't like ghost the ball
up from the bottom
and start a uh a proper review on
this so brick
index
H okay we'll see how these are being
I log
these I don't know why we're logging
struct we'll see why this is needed I
don't know if this is needed we'll
see Max score
Collision let me move my camera over a
bit for code
reviews we'll just do like
this up here and I'll go over
here so before it was just this like
naive bounce check I
Collision of a
stationary vertical line
interesting
[Music]
why vertical line segment with a moving
line segment
oh because there's going to be an hline
yeah
holy you're passing a whole bunch of
stuff
here as well as a struct
normally you either pass a ton of stuff
or you pass one
struct I don't know why this is I'm
going to I'm going to go through this
more before I do proper commentary on
this because I don't know if this is
reasonable looking at
it okay you have
fmin there's a bunch of math I'm going
to assume is correct
um for
now and we have
info and your returning
stuff that's kind of
weird Cal
yeah that's kind of odd
um smallest time collision with greatest
overlap and then let's see are these
different minus VX yeah okay so this
is you can see that they have the
horizontal and the vertical separate
they're structurally pretty
H I don't know enough about Collision
detection to know uh if this is the most
reasonable way of doing it to be fair
it seems kind of nutty to me for
breakout to have this much
the there's just a bunch of math for all
the individual sides and all the args
are different there's really nothing to
collapse
here what about this
Collision okay so this already has a
collision info in
to be fair I don't actually know how
um how the collisions are calculated in
the original breakout this is probably
like the more modern
game style where um you actually have
proper collisions on all sides of the
bricks I wouldn't be surprised if the
original game the reason it feels so
janky is they cheat and don't do a bunch
of this so probably actually this is
reasonable I mean I could imagine that
they just check like the uh you know
they just check the bottom of the brick
or something like that
okay so it looks like he actually does
do some pruning
here um to make sure that we're not
going to be checking all the bricks so
this is
good cuz if you were now to do this more
expensive Cal with all the brick that'
probably be that would probably be
bad given the per requirements that we
have
okay so here's the fast it's here's the
fast return this is good and
then check for
Collision if we found another
Collision this correctly skips the
paddle
Collision wait what
if the ball hits the wall before the
paddle then it skips the paddle
Collision that seems
sketchy we're going to have to play it
at least nice thing with these games is
you can just play them
collisions there's some logic some
weirdly nested logic I can see here for
sure and what's all
bounds ball could
Escape
huh that's
funny I mean it does make sense though
you're literally going to be running
this thing for you're going to be
running this game at like 20,000 times
real time or something so like the very
rare conditions do
happen destroy
brick I don't know why
there's well this is nice
here I see so this is where making this
actually makes things
nicer cuz there were some functions that
have a collision info and a ton of param
collisions we're now at like 500 lines
of code for breakout though which is
kind of
nutty you know what I'm going to
do I'm just going
to because there's like too much math in
stuff in here for me to even just review
it so what I'm going to do
plays okay that does felt that did feel
like I missed it and it probably would
have on the old version it probably
would have given it to
if it hits the oh no wait
what it definitely went through the
paddle before
right why is we why are we at Max Speed
all of a
perfectly this type of thing here is
very
Jank I don't know what it is that they
do in the actual breakout games if
there's like a Max angle or something
yeah no it just went right through my it
went through the paddle
right it seems like it does go through
the paddle
it definitely it feels better than
before so it's an
improvement surprising how like um
something something as simple as
breakout there's
actually quite a bit of nuance in how
the mechanics are implemented
that makes it feel uh substantially
janky or
right why is it immediately going to max
speed no that was sketch I totally hit
it that
time but it could just be that the
puffer fish is not the same size as the
ball or something right
that time I missed it I'm pretty
sure see you know I'm like it's missing
it that could literally just be the
rendered model though not being the same
size one last game and then I will
assess logic based on
that did I just I just fat fingered it
you saw that right it went right through
the
paddle so it seems like just the ball is
not quite as
large um
Ball's just not quite as large as it
should
be yeah so a lot of the times I'm losing
here because of that here let's let the
bot play this is a super old policy that
has not been trained on this version of
the game
let's see if it thinks
uh the
[Music]
same maybe Jake will be on for Connect 4
as well today that'd be
nice it's a pretty solid
policy I mean it's worked over lots of
different versions and it's just some
random thing I trained super
quick I bet it'll get stuck though when
you have uh when it has the smaller
paddle though with the uh the size of
the
bounds
see yeah so that was uh I can't can't
tell if it missed there but yeah so
there right there totally it just
couldn't see the uh that the it like it
thought it would have hit there and it
should have hit there but it just
didn't uh I think there it was
legitimately
off yeah so there it's legit off as
well uh you can see it it like it thinks
it's going to hit at the last second but
then it just doesn't because like the
bounce checking is not as generous as it
used to
be look at
that second
screen okay so now we know the second
screen works
code 581 lines for breakout is kind of
rough
um yeah
I might need David to walk me through
some of this this is a
I'm trying to think why this is so
convoluted
this is probably just the type of stuff
you have to deal with when you're
starting to get into like proper physics
right
because you don't just like Advance time
and then check if two things have
already like have already collided and
are there for overlapping right you
check whether they're going to collide
welcome YouTube
folks I'm kind of stuck here because
like this is is a good
PR does the thing I asked for maybe
there's still a couple edge cases or
whatever let's check the perf before I
decide anything
actually cuz if it's slow then that's
another
how do I okay I got to turn these stupid
notifications off
moves want it
free no free on the
N should be a free on the N right
so yeah that's still crazy fast so I
can't uh I mean that's plenty
there unless I mess anything up
I mean this is a solid little test I
think I merged this I say like hey if
you can simplify simplify if not I mean
this will be on the back burner
eventually important thing though this
is a nice stable
en way less janky than
before still very
yeah dude what the hell
why is this random guy stalking me on
YouTube
handled there wasn't all that much for
me to do other than just like to assess
the state of things in this one just a
bunch of physics and math Collision
stuff we definitely need better ways to
handle that
hi probably just somebody misclicked
Voice by
allocations
what
is this is probably costing
you a fair bit of perf
I don't know if letting you observe this
score is worth it
better got rid of the Malik that was the
biggest thing
nonsense and oh we're not at the end of
this thing
yet yeah these are nice little
improvements
make
[Music]
and then here's the meem copy again yet
when I see you reuse like recomputing
like an intermediate thing five times
you should probably take it out use it
twice it's fine to just do it you know
to just write it out is
fine okay random
move get your
Q just cleans up some of the
checks it's
fine good refactored as I adjust
there and
then oh
yeah this is
fine you have this intermediate
it Atari thing is Japanese term for
about to be oh okay I figured it just
like I figured it was like cursor
filling in nonsense
this is technically like exactly
duplicated code
here uh I don't really mind cuz it's
only
twice and it has like conditional logic
flow anyways
time right what's this useful for
training increase with larger board
size oh yeah we'll figure this out don't
worry about this
cool we'll end up making the AI like a
flag or
you told me here that um the game can go
longer than this
right oh wait no times
two yeah you're
good times
two hey
David bit code heavy once I started
stinging thinking about Ed Casa just
coming up with more I might pair it down
a bit
so the thing that like I'll tell you the
thing that bothers me sistic and it's
kind of silly but
like typically when there's like there's
complexity at least the way that I look
at things right and I did uh I merged
this
already
um okay so when when there's going to be
complex
and you can't find a way around
it at least in the short term you kind
of want to like commit one way or the
other I think so like you either are
going to commit to having a giant method
signature so that the Math logic is
going to be nice and
clean um or you like commit to putting
everything into a struct so that you
have like Fair like so that you don't
have these giant signatures
but like here it's there's a whole bunch
of stuff and there is uh a struct and
the struct gets like updated in place
with something that doesn't seem to
imply that it
does so there's a lot going on I can
show you like I don't don't know I guess
the only place I can even give you as a
comparison is what I did with like
puffer
N.H where is this so this is like a
bunch of complicated code right like
this this is a conf 2d conf 2D is really
complicated I don't want to have like I
want to basically be able to have this
look like the math of it and not have
like n arrow input or like you know net
Arrow weights or whatever so what I did
is I put the com 2D with the giant
method signature like this I wrote this
as plainly as I could yeah it's going to
be very nested but this is
legitimately the complexity of a
con and
then to bind this to make it simpler
right I have a struct for the conf 2D I
have a make function for the com
2D uh the make function just gives
you this object with all of the things
like computed for you all these
intermediates for you and now you just
have this layer and then when you
actually go to use this com after making
it right it's just going to take the
layer and the input and then yeah you
have this binding that has this
complexity but like something like this
maybe could be there I don't know I
would just like generally try to think
about trade doing the tradeoff in one
way or the other the middle of the road
thing where you have a bunch of prams
and a struct that gets updated is a
little bit
rough I see why you did it though it's
like legitimately there's like you're
kind of implementing your own little
physics engine in a way
if I remember correctly Alpha go papers
set max length two times board size
Force episode copied that if you copied
it from alphao then don't listen to me
and keep
that
yeah I mean I'm a lot more particular
than most people are um David it's kind
of like one of the things with a lot of
the way I build stuff
I have
whoops I even posted something like that
today yeah
like I get
uh I get like very very obsessive over
trying to keep things simple
where was the code review I was working
on oh
indexing you can just inline these
things if they're only used once but
whatever
good oh what's
this oh this is imp per test yeah you're
good great feedback improving it will
definitely improve the code
yeah well I mean to be fair I'm not
always going to be right in this area CU
like I keep finding things that I can do
better in this cuz I literally for
reference I've been coding in Python for
like 10 years and I had the same
ridiculous emphasis on Simplicity there
um but like there are language level
things in C that I'm still picking up I
haven't written C in 10 years up until
this
summer um so for instance
like I don't know I figured this thing
out the other day and this was really
cool for puffer
net I was going to use like an area
allocator but then I realized it was
even I could do something even
simpler here like I do this in a lot of
them so I allocate this thing allocates
its memory but it allocates enough
memory for the struct itself and for
things inside the
struct
so now when I make this thing and I make
it with this nice you know this nice
populating
syntax you return it you don't need to
make a free function for this you can
just free the linear layer and because
the pointers to the same memory you are
also freeing the weights at the same
time so I'm still figuring out nice
little things like this um just to keep
things Compact and
uh yeah generally that's one of the
places I
I do relatively well is making
complicated things simpler
refactor yeah I already did it I was
about to tell him something
now's
this I did merch okay cool
nice we've got the
go set
up kind of want to get this
thing
online what's the current state of the
of training on this thing
Spencer can we like do we have like
semide decent
policies to load in yet or
no CU we could get a policy deployed to
this thing pretty easily if you have uh
if you have it
training okay so here is the puffer
go we need to improve this board I think
confused dude are you dry in all the
tiles
individually what the heck
plus
bizarre I honestly have no idea what
this is I didn't really pay attention
because it's just for the renderer but
like
I mean do you use this for
like succeeded in baffling
me just a little
welcome what are you building or doing
currently fixing up Spencer's uh go game
renderer just cuz I saw the opportunity
to do so been merging some PRS to puffer
lib high performance reinforcement
learning and and play with a few of them
here and uh yeah we're going to
generally be training some probably
training some models on this mooba later
today I think I have a much better model
than this that's
trained got to go experiment with that
so doing a lot of stuff
quick it's just funny like the way that
this was drawn was a little
R gives me an excuse to mess with the
color palette at the same time
what am I doing
here being
silly yeah this makes no
sense I just did there
two
right well we don't actually know yet to
be fair I assume it's going to be plus
two have this minus
nine do you want me to
push uh hold on I'm messing with your
render right now Rend is a little
silly I'm to figure out is this even
correct so 1 2
here but you you're supposed to place it
on like the edge of the board I think
yeah you have some things that are a
little silly in the
so this is how it's supposed to actually
look
and then I'll have to adjust okay and
then this thing here just has to be one
there's some more silly things
here
go and then
that width should be equal
to
n grid size let's just do grid size here
actually grid
size then we can
do be
progress why is there a do width and a
do height and a DOT board width and a
DOT Board
this all right there you go now you got
a nice thicker
Grid or we have colors
[Music]
defined tile
color
oh mon
right going to get you your color
palette
just trying to think how I want to do
stuff with this
basically the hold up here is just um we
were thinking of putting all this stuff
like this side panel information on the
website but then you don't get it on the
local
version I mean not this stuff
necessarily but like we don't want to
have a side panel in this and then also
a separate side panel on the web I would
think
I actually like the way that you've been
doing this fencer with the side
panel I actually think it's pretty darn
good so I'm going to keep it for
now I'm just going to keep it like
this with the side
panel I think it would be a little bit
much to try to puffer color scheme go
right
I'm going to try it just to see if it
looks awful or not but I think it's
going to end up being a bit
much I think go is like a classic and it
probably needs like to keep its original
color scheme but we'll
uh we'll
see actually we're going to do the side
by side I feel confident it'll be much
I figure here we'll do the side by side
for you so here's the this is the
version before I mess with it right and
color so what this is just going to be
like puff
background and this will be puff White
uh this is too minimal as it hold on let
me at least give it a proper try cuz
that's going to
look that's too minimal
um board
I can do that as well Spencer let me
just try a couple things you're M so
actually I'll leave the decision to you
in this one I'll just leave the decision
to
you since I don't want to make a mess of
your uh your nice end but I'm going to
try a couple things just to see if you
like any of
I think either way it's going to need
piece artwork it's going to not need to
be uh your project you can do yeah but
out of respect for like you put a lot of
effort into this thing so if you just
want to keep it the original I'll say
sure let's keep it the original
doesn't mean I'm not going to try to see
if there isn't like a cool you know on
theme puffer
thing I think either way
the having flat-shaded Stones doesn't
work I think we're going to want to have
like um a PNG or whatever like an asset
that just has like a little bit of um
like a little bit of a gradient or
something that looks more like a stone
for
depth the other thing I could do hold on
is I could
be this is worse right this is like way
worse trying to do a combo like this is
way worse I think
you know what we could do that would I
think would be
better I mean we could do
um we could just Hue the stones a little
bit in the
pngs cuz I think the um they like the
black and
white ghost stones are really iconic
right black and white ghost stones are
really iconic so you got to keep it
pretty close to that
probably but
like can you just
like okay so like let's say that we do
that would probably be it the one thing
I was thinking that might be really
close to that would
take so here's like a black a black
stone where's the gradient tool
I can do this way quicker on Google
Slides just to check
right or
whatever don't they have like a gradient
tool or
whatever so we do like
this radient
cust
now let me just see if there's even
something that looks
good so this is not what we want we want
the opposite of this
no other way
around so it is this but just way less
aggressive so like
90 I was thinking like something like
this
like oh except you have to do the other
way right it's 255 minus 90
which is uh
165 or is it what is
on if you just like pick one of
these like yeah it works for
white or black right doesn't
it yeah if you like you just use these
as the stones these look
good but then this one just looks
terrible what colors did they use
here this is from White all the way
to 179
work the original Stones look better
they just look
better okay so we
find keep the stones mess with the
board it's a little obnoxious because
like we usually usually like I would do
it so like you use one color um like
cyan always goes like Canan is always
your color or something I was trying to
keep consistent
blue is red the other well it depends
what I've been doing for technically
puffer is just the cyan is what we do
but for M's I've kind of been liking uh
for like two-player stuff I've been
doing like cyan and red to distinguish
the players and I've been trying to keep
it somewhat
consistent like I don't know the moit is
um like what you're on like I made
radiant the blue side and then dire is
red side hold on yeah you
see same with TCG this actually I need
to tweak potentially some colors here
but
snazzy so I've been trying to keep like
Canan equals your
player I don't know if it works here
though
I mean it doesn't look bad it's just I'm
not sure if it's like as recognizably
go is there some like ying-yang thing to
to go or did I just make that up
like are
there cuz like I feel like if you could
you could totally do this with chess
right like people make crazy themed
chess sets all the time I don't know if
there's like there's it seems to me like
there's something more special about the
colors and go but I don't actually
know there
is okay if it's going to be like
disrespectful or something I'm not going
to do it
um yeah okay so there is some like
Chinese philosophy thing okay fine we'll
leave them as uh we'll leave them then
we'll leave the stones we're totally
allowed to mess with the background of
the board a little bit or something
uh it's not just delay on message it's
that X eats your
messages occasionally
which is also faster as
well that is
true the one obnoxious thing here is not
being able to see
um these things need like a border on
them or whatever
I think with the gradient pieces this
will
work you can make the board
bigger uh yeah I can do that as oh yeah
why why did I stop that that was
stupid let's do
this but that's actually kind of
clean if we improve the
yeah like having the separate was better
I
think we're starting to get to
I think we're starting to get to something respectable
here having the board like this is nice
you can't see the outline they just look
like Cuts in the board actually what if
we make the cuts in the board a little
bigger does that do
side the border on are do you think so
or do you think you can like have the
board look like it's
I can do the lines in a different
color I don't think it's better though
hold
on so what we want to do this in like
puff white or whatever
I'll make sure that this is
something that you're happy with we can
go back to the original colors and just
have it be like cut out or something
yeah you see how this looks this looks
bad
right I think that this looks
bad this is just like straight up a grid
okay so now
this right
this has
potential oh no that's an old message
okay so like this
versus
oops well we definitely don't want this
cleaner aren't the stones too big as
well are the stones like actually the
size that they touch each other when you
play or they need to just be reduced
like a little
bit oh they
are H they're a little
smaller what about edges on the
squares kind is hard to
see the black tiles
on the edges I believe the tiles touch
left
100% what about edges on the
squares
um okay so we can fix the Border thing
real
okay so this looks uh this looks looks
awful with these with the gray here
um but it's not going to look this bad
because we're going to just make like a
gradient
image we should probably just go make
that real
quick wonder if I like the
puff
backr
uh here let's
do this is outer
okay there we go so they're not
literally touching they're just very
close
right improvements
folks we should go get the uh
uh we should make the asset I
think I could make the board distinction
more
aggressive I think the only way I could
do that is I'd have to make the
background full black though which is a
bit much
I think it'll be fine though with the
uh with the
okay fixed and valid move bug perfect I
will merge that right after we get these
goh
Stones uh looking decent
like the mini mean yeah I just kind of
guessed with
it
um I'm trying to figure out
does anybody know how to do
this I haven't done uh I haven't done
gradient stuff in a while with
fill you can't like make your own color
this really weird
wait it might even be in rayb which
would be
better I don't know if it is
though oh wait
draw draw a circle
gradient that's better we can do it
without any
so this will just
be
X ccle
Y
look at
that thanks
see oh no that looks terrible you don't
even want to see
that yeah this is it
it we're going to try just for the heck
of
it oh yeah that's
awful that's actually
awful all right we go with the original
uh the original colors that's so bad
that's ridiculously bad holy
hell and you can still see the stones on
the edges yeah you can't see the Border
super well but
like can see the stones
larger didn't I try that
before okay here's the alternative
uh here
is the
this I don't think it looks anywhere
near near as good like this
though this just kind of looks
lame yeah this looks
lame for whatever reason having the
board be like the
got a topic for master thesis going to
be building a simulation for organ
development huh based on optimization
prams first thought I first thought I
had was doing RL and treating it like a
game yeah I mean RL will work for
arbitrary Sim types there's no
limitation to just
games we use games because they're fun
and interpretable and they like they're
pretty darn representative of a wide
range of problems
kind of everything is just a game at the
end of the
use uh depends what you're comfortable
with we've really been liking C for all
our Sims doesn't mean you have
to definitely doesn't mean that you have
to
probably python then C
yep what's got a good visualization
library that would be easy to
use um well this is in RB RB has
bindings for literally everything this
is what we use for stuff you can
literally do the like you can prototype
this in Python you can put it in C you
can do it in whatever if you want to use
rust if you like if you like rust than
use rust personally I absolutely hate
rust I do not
like heavy programming
languages to be fair I probably haven't
given it a proper try but i' highly I'd
be shocked uh if I ended up liking rust
I'd be totally shocked
let me get this right real quick so we
can ship this and I can stop playing
um I can stop playing it being designer
manually centering text okay there we
go capture
Gotcha Man main
issues so I wanted to give it a
shot mostly
C++ I mean I I to be fair I don't like
C++ either I've been very happy just
writing my Sims and
c and then that also makes it very easy
if you like for whatever crazy reason
you do need a little bit of C++ right
you can literally just rename like just
swap the compiler add your tiny bit of
C++ and then you have like 5% C++ 95%
C I mean it's just like safety is not a
feature that you need for many
applications is all it is so like it
causes you a bunch of grief in the name
of a feature that like many times you
don't even want or
need Spencer are you
around how's
n you're fine this just takes a second
to
like what was going to happen and do
like 80 80
Spencer ever tried Zig yeah I saw it and
it's like it has some cool things but
like I don't know I've gotten to a point
with programming lately
where like like I don't want the fancy
features anymore if that makes sense
right like the Zen at this point is just
like you know I had all these things and
then I learned that all that I needed
was simple conditional statements and
loops and
such all right well if you're happy with
this I will ship this and you can make
whatever small
changes and
oh uh Spencer you can pull all the like
the main thing is you now have a bunch
of redundant
variables you no longer need like board
X and board Y and all that
nonsense cuz
like the way rendered it I just got rid
of that
going to go learn C I mean the funny
thing is you don't need to learn
anything you already know it
right like if you've taken any s like
any single systems course you already
know it there's nothing to
learn like any literally any firste
computer science student can read the N
code uh for all these puffer M and there
are not going to be any surprises
it I was going to put it on the site
right now as encouragement for you to
get a baseline done
reading C is usually
okay not at the level to program as
easily so do you know what an address
sanitizer
is because C is only hard if you compile
without any address sanitizer or any
like additional debug Flags Okay that's
why that's why C is hard is because you
get like stupid like non-error messages
you get seg fault like
look okay wow see C++ arrays bounds
checking with like vector and like
python has bounds checking and like
memory safety and stuff you just compile
with this and this catches like 95% of
all the different ways you can shoot
yourself in the
foot this ABS bound checking as a
compile time option right you get like
you actually will get errors and
such this is the missing thing this is
why I personally I hated writing low-l
code for 10 years cuz like when I was
taught this in University nobody told me
these
existed it's pretty dumb
F
exercise yes
indeed if only we had one of those for
RL yeah no that's that's everyone's
experience in college like when they
don't tell you that these things exist
and there's literally no point it's
actually completely stupid it's like
it's just a dumb form of academic haing
that has absolutely no educational value
use the freaking address
sanitizer and write simple things
it's already done for you in uh in
puffer as well like we already have
everything set up nicely in the way
where it's super easy to add new
environments and like there's not a
giant stack of build tools that you have
to copy either we just have like some
compile arguments in a setup.py and like
an extra shell script with a resource
folder like there's not like you know
you see what I mean like it's just it's
now cuz I haven't decided on side panels
overall yet
okay where are we going to add your en
is the question of the day
this watching you hey
Nathan how's it going
switch to 3x3 grid why would you do
on
website from
2x4 oh I I see what you mean so uh it
doesn't rescale at the moment is the
problem like it doesn't rescale at the
moment but yeah you're right we can
totally do
that yeah what we may as
well for now it probably makes more
sense you're
right okay
so I'll just put go up here then
or we'll put like go up here
tactical I have meaning to mess with
colors and stuff
yet go is number one
game welcome
I think we I think I already know what
the top row is going to be for the uh
the
official
release I mean we have some big
environments
okay that'll be on the website in a few
thank you very much for the contribution
Spencer let's get a policy onto
it definitely need more policies for
these we only have policies for a few at
the moment like we've got this snake
policy which needs to be
updated oh well this
Pages we've got pong policy breakout
policy uh we don't have Connect 4 policy
on here yet yeah there are a few things
that need policy still I think it should
be pretty easy to get like these five
environments maybe even go like a basic
one so six environments should be
relatively easy with the policy TCG
tactics need work Robo Cod will need
work MOA I'm going to work on in a bit
here um but yeah like goal is to have
these things well
underway here's go
live I thought you wanted a pong policy
well we do need a pong policy ours is
dated and all also the default hyper
parameters don't really work very
well I mean it's decent but it's like
this was trained on an old version of
the environment it'll drop some points
now and
again same thing with the breakout one
it was trained on an old version of the
environment and it just doesn't train
very well either it takes way longer
than it
should so yeah we do need policies on
stuff uh I could go through this right
now but I think if Jake is
around I think Jake submitted a Connect
PR that's what I was thought yeah I was
messing on hyper prams good yeah you
just feel free to use the hardware
whenever you have it
take I haven't actually messed with
pbind
but awkward for anything non-trivial is
definitely a weird
yeah but like I was writing full M's in
scon and it was
fine
right invalid oh is a oneline PR
gotcha let's merge Jake's thing real
quick then
folks if you haven't started the puffer
yet please go ahead and do that it
really does help us out a
ton it's all free and open source
merch let's see how Connect 4 plays and
if so if it plays good we can uh we can
train policy or whatever with
this or I can let you all do the policy
side I don't really don't care either
way
somebody
win
no yo uh Jake why is it
reset you see it seems like it resets
when nobody is one unless I'm not seeing
it
nobody's one here
right and it
resets it shouldn't reset at the end if
you play an invalid move though
right or is that what you're
doing oh now that causes a
loss okay I see that's
fine that's actually fine
then and uh your scripted thing will
never do that
scripted did you not see the neural net
I put
in you got a full neural net in here my
friend
pretty cool right didn't take very much
code neural net and C loaded from p uh
loaded from pytorch
weird puffer N.H is a single file it's
like a 500 line implementation with no
other
um there it
goes it's much better
that that's kind of actually winning
suspiciously
fast lowle neural net implementations
and they're
fun um this is winning suspiciously
fast so we'll see if this policy is any
good or if there's a if it's like
exploited the network or something
episode length of eight moves suggests
that there's an exploit
I think the scripted agent is taking
invalid moves like the red opponent is
taking invalid moves
out
yeah let's just find it let's see if we
guys uh if we can figure it out
here just fix it
equal but then you step over invalid
moves
on but this gets assigned the highest
value right it's looking for the
lowest so this should never
trigger once it's taking values over
th000 or
something
possible no I'm still taking invalid
moves
I mean it shouldn't never be taking an
invalid move
oh why did I think that that would set
everything to
999 I don't know why I thought that
would set everything to
would be
nice if it were
stronger well I mean we'll be able to me
like we can set all that
there is this going to do the same win
over and
H are you seeing um is it doing
reasonable
flank is the thing it's doing actually
hard to beat
yeah it's kind of doing the same game
very often a lot
is 10 million stepper a very very simple
policy
we can just uh we can just add this one
for now I think
right we shouldn't need this
anymore oh we can leave it
in I think it'll silently Break
does this thing have to return an
INT
turn
you know people are going to want to
play against the bot instead of playing
against the scripted one at some point
but we can deal with that
later it's an rlin first and foremost
not an entertainment
thing it would be kind of cool to play
against
it just have like some like you know our
bot is One X Games versus users or
whatever we can do that later
and go ahead and deploy that for you
actually real quick
deploy
perfectly you can hold shift as well to
start playing
yourself kind of
cool is it
Go connect for bot is ready it'll be on
the web in a second as soon as that
thing
redeploys uh go is
well no Gobot
yet I mean I didn't really do anything
here this is Spencer's
environment all I did was tweak up
Graphics advise and
deploy Spencer wrote The Go
environment um
breakout we need new policy and stuff
and I'll push
that snake needs new policy but all
these are looking way
better um yeah there are a few M's that
we don't have online yet um probably we
will want to get some version of Robo
code in a good spot I really want to get
a contributor on Robo code specifically
actually I like might literally have one
in my DMs right
fun I was hoping I would just have a
robo code contributor in my
okay any more contributor stuff
whoops hold on I love
Windows they should call it not Windows
because it like freaking closes all your
windows with like random built-in
shortcuts that nobody asked
for wait was this the guy that was
trying to do Texas
holdom I thought there was another one
H I guess
not maybe it was this
okay it looks like stream's warmed up
nicely welcome
everyone uh I think we're going to do
something really cool next actually
because I have this policy on this
MOA we have this mooba game like mini
League of Legends or
DOTA and
um I got what looks like a decent policy
trained right
here has a nice learn curve on it I have
not seen what it actually looks like yet
so I'm going to take 2 minutes I'm going
to go use a restroom I'm going to grab a
drink and then we're going to see if we
can get stuff done on uh on that policy
plus any other contributor things for
the rest of the day um in the meantime
though if you have not
already please just start the repo it
really helps me out a ton we've had like
uh like 200 people joined the Discord in
the last few days but we've had you know
maybe 30 40 Stars added on it it really
just if everybody who joins the Discord
just Stars the darn repo it would really
help out a lot
um helps me with things like getting
this Library out there getting feedback
onboarding new people Etc anyways be
right
[Music]
here doesn't sa a policy interestingly
that's fine I can just SCP it over
go um I think that this is not loading
correctly
right yeah this is not loading
correctly because the uh the policy had
very good stats and this does not look
like good stats to
all right let's just make sure that I uh
let's let's see what the heck I just
loaded
one possibly loading wrong architector
or some other [ __ ]
H that doesn't make any sense no does
it because
over
here yeah look at the episode return
great that's weird though
because stats are up according to
this like way
up actually let's look at creeps
killed that's a good stat to look at
look all the stats are up on creeps
killed right
all the stats for creeps killed are at
their Max right here
means that if we're not seeing them
doing anything then something is loading
wrong or
whatever cuz they should be killing
creeps let's watch the
tank maybe it takes him a
while really shouldn't
what you got to imagine that it's
like some load
think I'm trying to think what other
things I didn't account
for and like loading this or whatever
oh I wonder if I broke anything with the
latest uh
refactor cuz
technically can I mess with some
stuff I messed with some things didn't I
from I mean I refuse to believe it's
getting those stats while being this
8,000 it's not that long
right I think it's like 10 per second or
whatever yeah it's not that
long it's a reasonable game
length I don't know did they actually
get lazy is it like is this somehow the
better regime right here
they're getting reward for this somehow
but I don't understand
how or I'm not loading correctly or
something in
that Realm
see they're doing more
stuff are they just kind of doing it
randomly
it's hard to say
weird part is that the value function
does actually blow up eventually with
support doesn't really get any
XP the other classes though are leveling
they don't seem to be leveling as much
as they should
be is weird
well I guess we're going to just do what
I uh what I was planning on originally
which is to make it so that um we have a
version of the environment that
does that plays against like a scripted
opponent I guess we'll just have to do
that cuz I can't really tell from the
Victorious
okay num
agents get a pass script
opponents
somewhere
script opponents
now I got to look for everywhere I've
hardcoded
now this is where we got to do the
um like the creep logic
is there even anything that needs to
change
is I think I can literally just call
creep AI on
and then the only thing I got to do is
set their way points appropriately
yeah so we assign
Lanes it's all we got to
oops
yeah it's this way
right yeah like
go
seriously failed to
open text file
anything oh they're running at me wait
what oh yeah CU this is loading an old
an old file right
yeah this is still clearly like a
trained model it's not doing what it's
supposed to be doing here
on now they're not doing anything
different
um okay let's see if this is getting
done
correctly
ah got to compile local
mobile
okay
so RI
stupid oh no here we are we're good I
thought mik was muted but now I should
mute mik cuz there's background noise
one sec
look at
that
so I mean it looks like they're all
just okay Mike if let me know if Mike is
picking up background noise I hope it
isn't
um look at this they're playing a
freaking game of
League with the scripted a eyes here is
like they're actually playing the
cool okay well now we need not both
teams to be
awkward I'm going to just paste this for
now
this now they should be using skills as
well
okay they immediately move
out we're watching this
Mana just took a hit but hasn't used any
skills
now rebuild or
something oh it didn't
rebuild or skill
policy um yeah I'm just what's going to
happen is I'm going to make this the
dire side policy
so that there's a fixed opponent to play
against so we basically we see if it can
figure out how to play against
um enemies that just like run down their
respective Lane assignments and try to
take towers and
stuff it'll look way
cooler that's for
okay they should spam skills
now oh yeah look at
h i mean they're actually freaking
they're playing the game here look at
this you got your 2v2 Bot there's no
like jungle roll because I I don't know
how to script a jungle AI so there's no
jungle roll
um
but we got the
tank going to be a tank
battle yeah look at
Tower wa could 100% commentate this as
if the Bots knew what they were
Advantage unfortunately not smart enough
to uh realize to back off of this Tower
here back to the fountain with
let me see how bad this is though
step I mean there are a few places
where have to be
[Music]
that's just
fine it's
fine uh this is the only one that needs
to
mooba found no field
script components
actually yeah we have crazy batch sizes
here
this has to
here this has to go up a little
go up a little
bit this
means this can just go up all the way up
here
uh there they are here come the Bots
they're going to spam their skills on
you
holy well they're going to spam their
skills harder than you can spam your
skills so
um I don't know do you have to like Farm
the wave and like try to get leveled up
or something
maybe neutrals I don't
know we'll
disappointing why is it still like
bolting I might so be inclined to
see if this perf test catches anything
seems like it does
xp4
level I less than 30
I okay so that fixes that bug small bug
but an important little fix
oops weird that it's then seg faulting
in training
OB space is given
as oh I know what it
is I just hardcoded a
thing yeah this will fix
anywhere else I have hardcoded
10 think so
go
cool
um so yeah you can see dire's already
starting to win
games but now we actually have something
to train
against and we will be able to see
victory over time or stats over time or
stuff like that
we're going to take a pretty substantial
perf
hit because the m is essentially
simulating twice as many minions
now um but I think this will be a good
first
run it's only an hour for a billion
exper a billion steps as well we'll let
this go for a
bit any other PRS or things I got to
look at in the meantime I would really
like to find a somebody for robo code
actually how is the pwn code is the pwn
code pretty
okay it was the breakout code that was
was the one that needed
um and that's already been
done is there anything else weird in
here no this is actually kind of fine
right that's kind of fun
we don't really need to go
really would be good to get somebody to
take on Robo
code I mean it's not even
um
tests I don't know what's up with Alexi
uh sion's pretty
good
um how's the robo code stuff
actually I mean it really shouldn't be
that much of
a it shouldn't be that hard for somebody
to take this on
right like I made this
file it's 300 lines it does Robo code
Basics really just need a Dev on
it probably a couple days I mean this
was only like a couple days of work for
me at most so I think it was even less I
might have just done that in like a
session so
uh probably within a couple days any
decent Dev could have that thing looking
a lot more like a proper Robo code
en which is funny because the original
Robo code project is like tens of
thousands of lines of God awul Java
oops I put it in the wrong I just
totally put this in the
wrong wrong Channel there we go
okay let's go take a look at the the
stats will be a good thing to
holy
uh Dynamics are definitely different
wait shouldn't
Dyer D should definitely be winning here
yeah you can see at the start the dire
is winning
initially but then already it starts
winning that doesn't seem
right I don't know maybe they just learn
to all Rush down mid and they win faster
that
way we'll see what this is
Towers yeah guess you can see
dire's got more
Towers we'll see what this ends up being
it's going to be kind of cool either
way I think if you we beat um if we just
beat this dumb scripted Bots that's
already going to be a pretty substantial
uh pretty substantial thing for this en
I mean maybe that's the Benchmark right
it's just like beating uh scripted Bots
and then we'll like get better scripted
Bots or like we'll replace the scripted
Bots with neural Nets so that you know
you have to beat a fixed opponent we'll
I'm trying to think of other things I
got to be doing for this um a few things
on the
website generally the two things that I
think
um well I have two complicated M that
I'm working on the MOBA and one other
then a robo code and the TCG are not
worth they need to be
yet everything else is looking
decent like these are all
within like a day work of having
reasonable
policies I
think I would really like to have Robo
code on here so we have 10
ms like Robo code would be like a
medium complexity M as
well this is going to need policy this
is going to need policies
time is it it's
4:29 yeah I kind of want my focus for n
to be on this until I finish it
though until I at least get it in like a
good enough spot where I'm like okay
this could be released you know
kind of curious with these policies like
it's getting these
spikes I'm just worried something is
wrong
here you know what I'm going to do I'm
going to pull like an intermediate
checkpoint that's what we'll do we'll
like just pull an intermediate
checkpoint
where' the command
go ah whatever
so
um I don't know about you but it seems
unlikely that these guys are winning
anything to
me wor there's got to be something wrong
with the way we're loading models or
something because on the logs it says
that they are winning sometimes doesn't
make any sense to
me this is probably the one we want to
watch
camps so the reason I'm watching the
scripted opponent here is just to see
um you know end of game or whatever what
happened cuz
something is not happening correctly
think the logs don't reflect what I'm
seeing
yeah look they the opponent they've got
a level 11
this is Win
right yeah now back to level
respawned literally thousand step game
right
it's not reflecting what I'm seeing at
all
better I just don't see how it's
possible that radiant team is
winning it looks like it's going up as
somehow I
mean it' be really weird if I were
loading the model wrong
I guess we'll just see if it actually
shows us training
like it looks like it's running the
scripted policy on both sides or
something but that should not be
possible so there's definitely something
screwy about the way I'm doing train and
eval because they never like they never
match up
sense I'm tempted to restart this with
like better logs
I mean this says that dire's winning
more often
but like there's no way that after a
couple minutes of training radiant is
ever winning a game
right well how's this
also why does this curve look like it's
going
both okay I mean I guess it's kind of
good that the episode length is going to
Trend upwards
because that means that maybe they're
actually fighting it out a
bit what level
I just don't believe
that the radiant has this level this
early we there are a lot of things I can
do to test this to be fair
let's see what the logs look like by
comparison
okay this should be
tracked let's see what this graph looks
like compared to the
others okay so it literally it's got
like a data
point okay now this one is reasonable
right you can actually see they get like
level two or whatever three and dire is
much higher
there yo I should only be running carb
sweeps and not normal yeah yeah us
generally uh carbs carbs is
good doing a little bit more work on
this then I'm going to call it
soon I got to get a
get some food and then get ready for
lips definitely are making progress
here like I don't feel like I've been
super productive the last few days but
if I actually look at what's gotten done
like there is consistent
progress if we can just figure out what
the heck is up with the
mooba I think it should be way easier to
reason about now that I have a scripted
opponent
version should be way easier to reason
about fact that radiant levels going up
is interesting for
yeah there's no way that there's any
radiant victories
right possible just the victory graph is
screwed
up we could just say the vict Victory
graft could be screwed
this these guys just are not doing
anything
okay well they're not random they are
actually getting on of base
now you can see that
right but like in the meantime right
look there's like these guys are getting
work
done there's no way they're winning
versus this
right oh they do actually have this tank
in
but like they're going to win the game
just doing this
right like I assume the tank is going to
just win on his
and here is uh the tank at level eight
about to push a big wave under this
Tower as well is take out the burst and
another wave
right so yeah like I guess technically
it doesn't know how to not get
zapped by the
t3s but um
uh and that's
basically house in-law what's
that okay like to be
fair we are actually seeing them get
some stuff done down mid
here like this tank is actually kind of
okay level five he's matching the enemy
three oh bouss yeah yeah I know Bal
okay inting
Sion yeah the these guys are not that
smart though these guys are like what it
looks like if I try to do that Strat and
then I just in and and I don't even get
any objectives or anything
I just don't believe that this thing is
ever winning so I like
presumably maybe this metric is messed
up
no but it says that the tank like the
levels are very high as
well the end of the
this are these somehow like just being
logged
wrong or something
okay show me the huge difference in
performance that this is supposed to
anything is my logging just bust like
what on Earth is
you have the victory condition right
there
I could do this I could maybe do this
headless
yeah no look they're already level eight
they're in
base
okay let's put some
oh well episode length just went
nuts so I think that this means that the
environment just
broke most
likely then the victory cons also got to
be broke
okay something is definitely bugged this
is not right
um look at all these dire victories as
well
right no radiant Victory
happening well actually when you run the
policy in here it looks
fine something corrup ing
logs I don't know it's five I'm going to
call for now call it for now um I'm
going
to get some food do some stuff I'm going
to think about this and uh yeah this is
going to be probably the next thing that
I try to figure out is how to get this
thing to actually train versus the
scripted opponents this feels like a
much more achievable goal than just
open-ended ELO as well
so um
probably streaming this on Friday I
would say I got some stuff to do
tomorrow um if you're interested in
contributing to any of this stuff
there's the Discord there's the GitHub
it's all pretty chill you don't need to
be a RL Guru you just have to be able to
write like simple procedural
code
um please do start the
repo starting the repo just helps me out
a huge amount
Mount really
does I mean the growth on this has been
amazing and I'm very happy that it's
been like this but this is the way it
needs to
be to keep doing all this stuff like
this and uh if you're interested in
deving some M's and having them
here making reinforcement learn and go
forward like that join the Discord
that's where we coordinate all that
stuff thanks